un bloque se encuentra en una posición
inicial x 0 y se encuentra en contacto
con un resorte no comprimido de más
insignificante el bloque se empuja hacia
atrás sobre una superficie sin fricción
desde la posición x igual a cero hasta x
igual a menos de como se muestra en la
figura de arriba comprimiendo el resorte
una cantidad delta x igual a d
el bloque comienza aquí y está en
contacto con el resorte por lo que al
inicio el resorte no está comprimido
solamente está tocando el bloque y luego
comenzamos a comprimir el resorte
empujando el bloque hacia la izquierda y
lo comprimimos una distancia de aquí
está del tra x igual a d
así que movemos este bloque hacia la
izquierda una distancia de lo que
comprime el resorte el bloque se libera
cuando x es igual a 0 el bloque pasa por
una parte rugosa del camino y
eventualmente regresa a una posición de
reposo x igual a 3 d al comprimir el
resorte estamos realizando trabajo así
el trabajo que estamos realizando se
almacena como energía potencial en el
sistema bloque resorte cuando lo
soltamos la energía potencial se
transforma en energía cinética por lo
que el bloque se va a acelerar hasta
llegar de nuevo a x0 en donde el resorte
deja de estar comprimido y ya no va a
estar empujando al bloque pero ahora el
bloque tiene energía cinética y si esta
parte gris de aquí no tuviera fricción
el bloque se movería para siempre ya que
en este problema suponemos que no hay
resistencia al aire pero en esta parte
si hay fricción por lo que el bloque se
va a desacelerar con una tasa constante
ya que tenemos una fuerza de fricción
constante que se aplica a este bloque
nos dicen el coeficiente de fricción
cinética entre el bloque y la parte
rugosa del camino es muy inciso en los
ejes coordenadas de abajo dibuja y
etiqueta una gráfica de las siguientes
dos cantidades como función de la
posición del bloque entre x igual a
menos de iu x igual a 3 d
no es necesario que calcules los valores
del eje vertical pero debe usar la misma
escala vertical para ambas cantidades y
la energía cinética cae del bloque 2 y
la energía potencial del sistema bloque
resorte primero vamos a enfocarnos en la
energía potencial
ya que en la primera parte del problema
cuando comprimimos el resorte es cuando
comenzamos a poner energía potencial en
este sistema bloque resorte así que cuál
es la energía potencial almacenada en un
resorte la energía potencial es igual a
un medio porque la constante del resorte
multiplicado por lo que se comprimió el
resorte al cuadrado delta x al cuadrado
delta x es que tanto comprimimos el
resorte y lo elevamos al cuadrado si lo
que acabo de escribir les es
completamente desconocido los invito a
ver los vídeos que tenemos en carnac a
demi sobre la energía potencial
almacenada en los resortes o el trabajo
necesario para comprimir el resorte ya
que dicho trabajo necesario para
comprimir el resorte
será la energía potencial que pondremos
en el sistema aquí conforme comprimimos
el resorte
de terminaremos con una energía
potencial igual a un medio de k la
constante del resorte multiplicada por
delta equis y delta x es d así que aquí
ponemos d al cuadrado vamos a graficar
esto aquí abajo justo cuando estamos en
x igual a cero no tenemos energía
potencial en nuestro sistema pero
comenzamos a comprimir el resorte y
cuando llegamos a x igual a menos de
tendremos una energía potencial de un
medio por la constante del resorte por d
al cuadrado digamos que este valor en el
eje de la energía se encuentra por acá
aquí es un medio de cada por d al
cuadrado y es la energía que tendremos
cuando x sea igual a menos de es decir
cuando hayamos comprimido el resorte
hasta menos de esta no será una relación
lineal recuerden que la energía
potencial es igual a un medio por k
por delta x al cuadrado lo que
comprimimos el resorte al cuadrado así
que la energía potencial aumenta al
cuadrado de lo que comprimimos el
resorte
así que si comprimimos el resorte a la
mitad tendremos un cuarto de la energía
potencial por lo que veremos esto como
el lado izquierdo de una parábola más o
menos así esta es la energía potencial
cuando llegamos a este punto en el que
hemos comprimido completamente al
resorte y lo soltamos qué va a pasar
pues la energía potencial se va a
transformar en energía cinética por lo
que conforme el resorte acelera al
bloque vamos a ir bajando esta curva de
energía potencial hacia la derecha y
después se convierte en energía cinética
así que la energía potencial más la
energía cinética tienen que ser
constantes al menos durante este periodo
de x igual a menos de hasta x igual a 0
la energía cinética comienza en cero
está estacionaria y después el bloque
comienza a acelerarse de manera que la
suma de estas dos cosas debe ser
a un medio por cada acorde al cuadrado
como pueden ver si suman estas dos
curvas en cualquier posición el
resultado siempre será igual a este
valor de manera que cuando llegamos a x
igual a 0 toda la energía potencial ha
sido transformada en energía cinética ya
teniendo esta energía simétrica se
mantendría en este nivel para siempre si
no tuviéramos fricción ni resistencia al
aire pero sabemos que el bloque se
detiene cuando x es igual a 3 d por lo
que en este punto se ha terminado toda
la energía cinética y en que se habrá
transformado esta valla seguramente se
transformó en calor debido a la fricción
recuerden que no se puede crear la
energía de la nada la energía se
transforma de una forma a otra así que
la pregunta es qué tipo de curva es esta
podemos conectar esto con una línea es
algún tipo de curva
aquí lo importante es darnos cuenta de
que tenemos una fuerza de flexión
constante durante todo el tiempo que el
bloque se está desacelerando no está
cambiando el coeficiente de fricción ni
la fuerza de fricción ni tampoco cambia
la masa del bloque por lo que la fuerza
de fricción no cambia y va a actuar en
contra del movimiento del bloque en
esencia pueden ver a la fricción como
algo que hace un trabajo negativo de
manera que le quita energía al sistema
si lo piensan relacionado a la distancia
durante la misma cantidad de distancia
va a estar quitando la misma cantidad de
energía va a estar realizando la misma
cantidad de trabajo negativo por lo que
esto se va a estar decremento no
linealmente así que lo dibujamos así un
decremento lineal aquí debemos recordar
que estamos graficando energía contra
posición no velocidad contra posición ni
velocidad contra tiempo o energía contra
tiempo
es energía contraposición y esto es lo
que nos da esta relación lineal de aquí
así que tenemos la energía cinética acá
del bloque que pusimos en magenta esto
es energía cinética y en azul tenemos
y energía potencial energía potencial